thanks guys I'm joined now by your karo
Nakamura and despite the fact that it's
not his birthday yet he did get a great
birthday gift which will not a gift I
suppose a hard-fought earned point by
beating former world champion vision on
the code can you tell me a little bit
about how the game went your thoughts on
it yeah so I mean this she kind of
walked into some preparation something
that I prepared I think he thought it
would surprise me but it wasn't really
surprised um and really there was a
critical position i think around moves
17 remove 18 after which she played b5
which I had not looked at before the
game and after he played b5 I went into
long think and I decided to play this
rook bd1 which I think objectively is
correct on and I suspect that probably
it's it's always a little bit better but
it's not much better but I think one's
vishy allowed this be four idea and his
Queen got stuck on e4 i think it was
always going to be quite difficult there
are always some practical difficulties
and eventually i mean he cracked because
it's just it's a very hard position just
kind of sit and do nothing and I mean
it's kind of cruel that when he when he
played this move g6 it basically was
losing MOOCs allowed me to go h5 and
then got a structure where the night was
always better than bishop so I mean it
certainly is nice to win but of course
it's long tournament so it's not not
that big of a deal you know and
optically after vishy sacrificed the
pawn on d5 and he has his rooks on cd8
the bishops are raking down on the
queenside and the night seems very out
of play on a 3 i'm assuming they
obviously you had looked at that part of
the the opening preparation prior to
that and decided that it was okay for
white i hadn't looked at b5 so no I
hadn't really looked at that but
nevertheless it's still it still is
always a pawn and especially with the
strong passed upon the sound of the pawn
on d5 which can possibly go to d7
dependent depending on the situation on
there there's always more than enough
enough play for white so I don't think
it's really I don't think there's any
risk at least being just a draw I think
maybe there's wish you could have played
better certainly but I think it's always
from a practical standpoint quite
difficult to defend and you know your
fans out there have been commenting on
the fact that your style of play seems
to really be maturing you know you get
these great positions were you able to
just kind of squeeze and squeeze until
eventually your opponent cracks and it
seems like that is exactly what you need
as you run up to a world
pionship run here can you tell me your
thoughts on the upcoming candidates
match and what your plans are for the
future of it well first of all it's a
tournament not a match match would would
give me much better odds of qualifying
but it's obviously going to be very
strong tournament most players here are
competing in it so it's I'm kind of
using this as warm up in as a warm up in
a way to just get ready for it again
everyone is very strong so I'm just
going to try and do my best and we'll
see what happens well you heard it here
first two carros plan is to play as best
and see what happens back to you guys